Hi, everyone. My
name is Dan Boerner,
and I champion
the graph at Apollo.
And in this talk,
I wanted to share my thoughts
about the human
side of GraphQL
by focusing on
the people involved
with adopting the technology,
their motivations,
objectives,
and how they're
managing the change
from a traditional point to
point API to a query
based unified
graph. Now everything I share
today comes from what we've
learned from others that are
evangelizing and championing
the use of GraphQL in their
organizations, and you can see
their logos on
the screen here.
And I'd like to give special
thanks to the panelists shown
here who joined from
Netflix, Zillow,
and Dava and Expedia recently
to discuss this very topic at
a recent GraphQL
summit roundtable.
And if you're interested in
hearing a great interactive
discussion on this topic,
you can find a recording at
the link below or by visiting
summit dot graph q l dot com.
Now anytime I see
an exponential
adoption curve,
I think about the underlying
motivations that are
driving the change.
In this case, the curve shows
the number of downloads of
Apollo's open source GraphQL
client over time.
And this is
a helpful proxy for
overall GraphQL adoption.
I think the curve
makes a strong
argument that
GraphQL is one of
the biggest innovations in API
technology in our generation.
So it's worth first
to understand
what's going on.
What's driving this adoption?
And while I think like other
innovations, cloud
native computing,
containerization,
reactive programming,
it's natural to try to explain
the rapid adoption
from a technical
point of view by
focusing on how
this new innovation is better
than the old in
various technical
aspects. Now we'll
get into a few
of the technical benefits of
GraphQL in a moment,
but I think that focusing on
the technical benefits alone
leaves out a big
part of why any
of these innovations take root
and spread quickly.
And I I think that's because
successful innovations provide
better solutions to problems
that people face,
to teams face,
to human problems.
And those solutions help them
build their products and bring
them to market,
and that's what really drives
the change.
Now in my career,
I've been involved
with a number
of large scale tech adoption
efforts and some of which have
been more successful
than others.
And I have two observations.
One, widespread
adoption of any
new technology is
very difficult
and time consuming.
And most adoption
efforts, frankly,
don't succeed.
They don't reach
their goals.
And my hypothesis is that it's
only innovation
that solve both
technical and human problems
that justify the large amount
of time and effort required to
successfully see them spread
across the enterprise.
Without that
return on effort,
the initiatives fade,
and they fall short of their
original goals.
And let's see if we can tease
out why that might be so by
answering a few questions.
What is motivating,
in this case,
a fundamental change
to our API stack?
What resistance do we face and
do we encounter when we try to
make this change and why?
And in face of
that resistance,
how can we create space and
safety so that that change can
happen and can be absorbed?
Let's begin first
with motivations
and and the problems
that GraphQL
solves. Now from a simplistic
tactical point of view,
GraphQL is essentially defined
by three things.
It's an API query language.
Much like SQL
queries databases,
you can use GraphQL to query
across APIs.
Now, secondly, it's a stable,
strongly typed,
declarative API contract,
which is captured in a schema
definition language
or SDL file.
And third, it's
a runtime system.
Right? There's
a client library,
gateway, and
server to make and
process requests,
to route them to
their underlying
services or data layers,
and then to return composed
responses back to the client.
And GraphQL solves
a large number
of technical problems,
and they're well understood,
and they're well explained in
many talks and and
resources online.
So I won't dwell on them today
other than to say that I think
they're very compelling,
and a lot of
companies find them
compelling. But if we want to
have a widespread
and successful
adoption of GraphQL
across the whole
enterprise, let's
check-in with
our hypothesis.
And it tells us
that we need to
solve both technical
and human problems.
So let's look at what kind of
human problems exist in our
typical service
oriented architecture.
Now I'll start
with the viewpoint
of an application or
a front end team.
And this wealth
of service APIs
and data reminds
me of the phrase,
water, water everywhere,
but not a drop to drink.
Because in order
to build products
from all those experiences,
to build experiences
from services,
I should say,
those application
teams have to integrate with
many different APIs.
They have to deal
with many API
versions. They
have to configure
API endpoints, learn about
different API idioms
and syntaxes,
and orchestrate multiple
calls together.
And as a result,
a lot of logic gets built into
the clients, into
the front ends.
And if that was done once,
that might be okay,
but it's not.
That logic is duplicated into
each application or
each front end,
and that duplication
causes two
serious problems for people.
One, for internal
product teams,
all that duplicated
logic means
each new experience or product
feature has to be
built multiple times,
slowing innovation.
For customers, it
leads to a fragmented
customer experience when they
use different
clients or devices.
And this fragmentation
is leading
to frustration and a dizzying
amount of difference for
differences' sake.
We see this across experiences
all over across the web and
applications across
all industries.
Expedia, for example,
had this problem,
and they turned
to the graph to
unify their customer
experience.
And they coupled
a unified graph,
a design system,
and a component
architecture to
create a unified customer
experience across all their
touch points. And you can see
the benefits that their team
called out with
this approach.
But it's not just travel.
In retail, Walmart turned to
the graph to create a seamless
shopping experience
across their
online and in store
applications,
which had previously been
completely separate
and accessed
through separate
tabs in the user
interface. With
a unified graph,
they were able to unify and
create a seamless customer
experience across web, iOS,
and Android in record time,
just in time for
Black Friday.
So you can enjoy
this experience
by visiting Walmart today.
And those are
just two examples
of problems faced by customers
and application teams.
But what about service teams?
Well, this might
be a view from
the services team perspective
Managing all of
those connections,
all of those
client dependencies
is time consuming.
Managing the different
versions,
convincing clients to upgrade
to new ones, or hopefully to
deprecate and move
off very old ones,
it's all overhead.
Not to mention requests from
enterprise architecture teams
or IT to unify on,
say, an API gateway.
It can feel very
overwhelming,
and it leaves very little time
to focus on improving their
services'
underlying functionality
or performance,
let alone the cost
of the occasional
need to architect completely
their service.
But what's worse,
even if they do these things,
it still pushes all
that complexity
down to each client where it
gets duplicated.
So many teams have built front
end APIs in the back end for
front end pattern to simplify
the complexity Steam quickly
Steam quickly. So
more human problems.
We've got version
and API endpoint
management,
direct coordination
between apps and
service teams,
duplication of logic,
slowing experimentation,
and new feature rollout.
So let's briefly turn to how
GraphQL addresses these very
real real and very
human problems.
First on the left,
it's an API built for
building products.
It's freed from
managing service
endpoints and orchestration.
App development
teams can focus
on experiences,
not integration.
Second, it's a query language
that's tailored for use.
Apps pick what they need from
a shared common contract,
optimizing performance and
removing complexity from each
application. Third,
in the middle,
the unified representation of
your services, data,
and digital capabilities
is created,
each capability
is expressed as
declarative abstract contract
via schema and
unified together
into a composed
super graph schema.
Now an insulating
layer is the fourth
step. On the service side,
on the right side,
decoupled from
those direct app
client dependencies,
service teams can focus on
optimizing their capabilities
and architecture without fear
of breaking changes,
and they can even reimplement
their architecture
behind a safe
typed contract without even
letting their clients know.
And that
technical architecture
empowers new
collaboration models
as well. On the left,
app teams bring
their understanding
of the customer problem,
the customer experience,
and what's needed
to build it.
On the right, service teams
bring their domain
declarative,
strongly strongly
typed, abstract
schema contract
that once built
allows each team
to focus on what
they do best.
And then revising the schema
contract as needed
in a lightweight,
backwards compatible manner,
thanks to automatic schema and
composition checks offered by
Apollo's graph platform.
Now this sounds
fantastic. No?
Everyone's working together to
leverage a new
API paradigm and
technology to get
more done with
less hassle.
But it's a big
change, isn't it?
Service teams and front end
teams coming together design
an API doesn't
happen overnight.
So let's let's
see what changes
that that provokes.
And As much as we'd like to
think that we're hyperrational
beings who evaluate the merits
of each new technology,
logically,
it turns out we're
people. We're human.
And humans have
an innate tendency
to minimize threats
and seek safety.
And, commonly,
we see major tech
changes like GraphQL provoke
some of these
triggers. Fairness.
My hard fought skills,
are they gonna be
made obsolete?
Is everything changing?
I have no certainty.
Am I losing control?
Are others now telling me what
my service what my
team should be doing,
what good is?
That affects my
sense of autonomy.
Now in the recent
roundtable I hosted,
Steven Spalding
of Netflix noted
that these triggers
are actually
biological in nature. Nature.
They're identified
by our amygdala
as a survival mechanism.
And our lizard bean
brain actually
tells us to run away from some
of these proposed
tactical changes
before a rational engineering
mind has even gotten a chance
to consider them, or worse,
to fight back with
every argument
we can find.
Now it's perfectly natural to
think that we can
just dispassionately
compare the benefits
of a query
language or a new
server architecture.
But it turns out we need to
identify and address the human
triggers that are happening
along the way.
And that's not
intuitive, is it?
Because as an evangelist
of an innovation
, when I trigger
a fight or flight
response in someone I'm trying
to convince, what
what's my response?
Well, it's only
to push harder,
to fight back with
fresh arguments
or to give chase,
essentially
attacking them with
believe me, believe me.
And that just makes it worse.
That just creates
more triggers.
So if change
necessarily triggers
base emotions in those we seek
to convince, what can we do?
Is there a way to avoid this
conflict and avoid
these triggers?
Well, I wish I
could say I believe
there was, but we
discussed this
topic in the roundtable,
and we all came to
the same conclusion.
Friction or conflict is just
another word for interaction.
All big leaps come
from a controlled
amount of struggle
and friction.
And second,
diversity of thought
is the source of insight.
It's not to be avoided.
Knowing where your
blind spots are,
knowing what you
don't even know
you don't know is crucial to
making discoveries.
And third, avoiding
conflict via
path of least resistance isn't
healthy in relationships,
and it's not healthy
in system design.
It leads to extra layers and
complexity being
built to avoid
the need to come together and
reconcile those differences.
So, again, great.
What do we do then?
If friction and conflict are
inevitable and they're not to
be avoided, what can or what
should we do to manage that
change and the reactions that
come about?
Well, let's talk about a few
tools that you can
use to promote
that positive friction that we
talk about.
Broadly speaking,
there's four that I'll share
with you today. The
first is empathy.
Rather than forcing a solution
on others because
it's technically
better, try adopting a product
mindset and work to figure out
your customer's problems,
the problem that the adopting
teams have.
By thinking and
talking in terms
of other people's interests,
what they care about,
we gain empathy,
and that leads to trust.
And trust is what we need to
encourage change
and work through
fear and doubt.
Second, shift
attention to common
outcomes. The best way to find
common ground is
not to technically
crush any doubt or push back
with the awesome force of your
will and persuasion.
That energy only increases
resistance to new ideas.
But rather,
redirect to
discussion of common
outcomes that you all seek.
It's very difficult
to align on
approach if you don't have
alignment on your goals,
and the more agreement
on outcomes,
the easier it is to explore
solutions that
meet those needs.
Third, demonstrate
versus scold.
When we want new behavior,
we can demand it,
we can criticize noncompliance
or resistance, or
we can demonstrate
and show its value.
And often, this means actually
rolling up your sleeves and
working with those
adopting teams.
Putting skin in the game not
only shows your
commitment to outcomes,
but helps you understand where
changes are needed
to your current
approach. So
adopting a show and
tell approach
with the emphasis
on show is a practical
tool you can use.
And finally, and perhaps most
importantly, embrace
new mindsets.
At Apollo, we've seen many
companies adopt
GraphQL at scale
across our organization,
and we've observed
a very natural
instinct to see
the new in terms
of the familiar.
I mean, we've been doing APIs
as a community, right,
for a long time.
So adding a query
language across
multiple APIs, that's great,
but the shape and the purpose
of every API,
that doesn't need
to change, does it?
Well, our experience has been
that when you take
that approach,
when you try to
fit the new into
the old,
you often miss out on much of
the value of the change.
And in the case of APIs,
there's a strong consensus now
about the power and importance
of designing with
an API first mindset.
Right? But if we look
a little deeper,
if those APIs are designed for
each service by each service
team independently and they
reflect only the view point of
view of the service owner,
then they're in a sense thrown
over the wall to
the front end.
And while consuming
multiple of
them in a single query is
mechanically better,
it doesn't really
address the complexity
problem. Whereas,
if we adopt a true customer
mindset for APIs,
we see we need
a connected set of APIs,
a graph shaped for
use by its clients,
not its underlying services.
And designing such
an interconnected
graph requires a much deeper
level of collaboration,
doesn't it?
And that pulls our
teams together
to build something
that truly captures,
something long lasting,
something durable.
And that's an evolving API
contract that offers a unified
and interconnected set of data
and capabilities
built upon but
abstracted away
from the underlying
service and data laters.
And that's just more valuable
than enabling queries.
So let's talk about a few
takeaways to
summarize the topics
that we've covered today.
First, tech
adoption is a human
endeavor. If your organization
is adopting GraphQL,
your people are
dealing with change.
And along with the benefits,
the value of new technologies
such as GraphQL,
change often triggers
resistance.
Constructive
friction is needed
to advance, to
make the leaps.
To avoid change is a siren's
call to the rocks.
It sounds attractive
to avoid it,
but, ultimately,
it's destructive.
Rather, by
practicing empathy,
shifting focus,
demonstrating success,
and adopting new mindsets,
you can create a healthy space
for change and
healthy conflict.
And, ultimately,
and this is borne
out over across
a hundred or so companies that
we've talked to about
GraphQL adoption.
Human factors
affect the success
of tech adoption more than
tactical factors do.
And that's the end
of our talk today.
I wanna thank Connected Data
World for this opportunity to
reach you today and to you for
watching the presentation.
For more content on GraphQL,
the unified graph,
Apollo's graph platform,
and more about
how companies can
get the most value
out of adopting
GraphQL, please
visit our site,
our YouTube channel.
And if you wanna continue
the conversation
directly with me,
please reach out
via Twitter or
the email addresses
here. And thank you.